bootleg here podcast special guest all
the way from the UK hello day folks Lord
Apex is here shout out to all you cheeky
[ __ ] big facts big facts
uh before we have you wrap just shout
out what you got going on man let's
[ __ ] you know your your area I'm
really relaxing right now uh California
education advice it's my first time out
here how do you like it smoking my trees
it's beautiful can you smoke trees
everywhere in the UK or is it illegal I
do but I don't know it's still illegal
but you know but it's a world there's a
way yeah uh you know that's it man I'm
out here relaxing I'm about to start my
first album
and uh so we're just gonna be in the
shooter the whole time
and I'm just I'll just go with the flow
with the whole [ __ ] that's kind of how I
ended up high you know it's how you
ended up out here you just rap go with
the flowing life is like L.A well let's
get to it man throw that [ __ ]
beat on Lord Apex
come on Lord are you folks West London
elevation meditation project
oh my guys I Ain't Gonna Shine On
individual names you already know who
you are yeah
yo
[Music]
yeah it's like I couldn't tell you how I
go ahead days I'm still surprised mom
seen it starve in his eyes it went hard
to decide they ain't seen the calm and
the stride if it's hard to divide me
homies coming from a place where all the
same respected unless their energy is
hectic glad she checked it she gonna
listen to me daily like a horoscope some
on the blocks if one of quote some
brewskies hey Shane funny you know
Drewsky dog to the Lost train back to
city was a money mode shorty sweep the
zip spot of Honeycombs buy me clothes
trying to keep it humble with this runny
nose cut 95s and no wise so I caught
runny nose and been caught me clothes
they've been sitting like a tree sweet
clean being a fiend being a dealer all
right sober and the Steeler just saw one
day he could fix the whip up like a wee
the dealer I need tequila keep me active
while I spill my heart poison Center
darts as freshly sharpened from the new
betrayal due to throw like Robo off the
Smoothie what I do to kill due to steal
I'm trying to set a cell grow old and
tell it tell I never met her well it's
too Majestic for this city boy but every
time my nephew crack a smile that [ __ ]
give me joy if my nan Could See Me Now
she'd probably beat my ass we was first
and last and all them urgent tossed at
her to also we just kept the whiskey in
the circle floss well first across but
if you need the knowledge he was first
the class yeah
slide
yeah
damn hot sunk again so I figured script
new flow for this new low trying to
debunk again depression so we stunk
again my fingers probably stunk again
it's wax on wax off how the process get
repeated way before the [ __ ] deep to
let AP tell you a secret dog I know I'm
good buddy but I fear nobody [ __ ] up
the love I was given ain't no homebody
until apologies and forgiveness and I
was slow buddy trying to get a gift for
life I don't like myself so we don't
matter who I'm with tonight as long as
she gonna get the pipes see hatred
growing small places like parasites but
sometimes they only lost a second hot
candle wax AB the conductor study truck
and how I kind of tracks it's just the
one that I would flat grow by the
cabbage patches I've been by my jungle
dog lions and heating is where the
famine off the meat there ain't too many
ways to get it where it's squat free top
free about to split the Gap the junior
welcome like to knock knees doubt they
caught the crap so we gonna seal all
right and block streets oh
Lord Apex
what's your IG man how can they follow
you Sensei Apex everywhere go run that
[ __ ] up man go follow him shout out to
West London in the building West London
Lewis fire hello fan zy all my boys I
see you let's go we'll look at podcast
let's go follow this man
hey you just watched a crazy freestyle
and we drop one every week sometimes
more than once a week uh and they're
always presented by our family at LRG
now I love LRG I'm wearing look I'm
gonna just show you the new shorts I got
from them check out them shorts my boy
you know what I'm saying and got the
plain black tea
plain black lrgt you know what I mean
listen lrg's back they just dropped the
crazy Jason hoodie with Jadakiss that's
from like 2008 for Halloween [ __ ]
Flames go to the website
l-r-g.com and this is crazy because
they're giving you 30 off when you use
the promo code bootleg 30 off that's a
significant amount of money you're going
to be saving when you go to lrg's
website Christmas is coming save 30 off
just by going to the website and using
the promo code bootleg L Dash R g.com
we'll see you next week with a crazy
freestyle